barrett la forme est ce que méline peut
apporter les accessoires s'il vous plaît
enfin une fervente croyante et je
voulais
mélina porte quelques accessoires pour
cette interview croyances
très bien
c'est parti
les us
non
est ce que vous croyez en dieu dans la
pièce jeudi et pourquoi j'avais mon dieu
je suis folle je ne crois en rien mais
si je crois en live ici je crois en la
vie voilà je vous croyais on vous laisse
avec un jeu brille aux anges gardiens
oui aux anges tout court oui gardien pas
gardien yann a dit mal de mauvaises en
jeu si oui oui oui oui il ya des des
diablotins
ouais elle souffrait au père noël plus
nos rial non non non je fais attention à
mon corps maintenant non plaisir quand
j'étais petit j'ai cru que je n'y ai
plus crue et gilles recrues ouais oui ça
peut peut-être mon revenir en dessous du
marché vous y croyez peut-être ou
d'autres veiller à la panenka serait due
bien ensemble ça rappelle là où vous
voyez chantôme oui oh oui heureusement
que ce que vous croyez à la
réincarnation
moi je crois qu'on a plusieurs vies des
ânes en phase iib iii un cas comme dans
l'autre sens car oui on sera encore me
l'a pas dit non tout à fait superman
c'est qu'il est assis da ba c'est celui
qui vole la au superman et là où il y
avait dix comme celle qui faisait le
joker
ouais
ramzy l'avez inventé moyens man c'est le
mec qui volaient les assassins est ce
que vous croyez à la fidélité
maintenant oui à encore pourquoi je vous
demande de vous arrêter
est-ce que c'est pas votre émission s
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour à l'amour sans sexe ouais ça tombe
sur vous muriel le sens des mots et je
crois moi et là mon sens aix aussi c'est
bien ça marche à tous les coups foot
mais là je vous demande pas est la nièce
de michel drucker
est-ce que jusque là où cela est oublié
cette question est est ce que vous
croyez qu'on peut faire l'amour cinq
fois de suite
muriel je trouverais bezard j'aime pas
très beaucoup de chiffres impairs donc
je serais plutôt pour 6 poursuit